hello guys my name is Jenna and welcome
to another Sparky dev vlog sir this is
della comma seven and I have been very
very hard at work over the last week and
so many things have changed
unfortunately well this isn't really
unfortunate but all the things that have
changed have been kind of internal under
the hood changes so like if I were to
run this right now
you would see that basically it's kind
of looking exactly the same right in
fact I think it's looking pretty much
exactly the same as it was in fact let
me just quickly just to add to the
effect I've even got that whole set
gloss value thing I might just get rid
of it in fact
just for the dagger the thing that I was
showing you guys last time but I think
I've got anywhere else there so then the
dagger should now be fairly glossy yeah
anyway yeah you can kind of see that no
much has changed it kind of looks the
same
however oh man so much so much has
changed and I'm gonna kind of go through
what I've done under the hood because
there are a lot of changes and kind of
probably what I'm gonna what I'm gonna
do over the next week as well so first
of all there are a few kind of user
things that have changed as well like
you if you were to look at test 3d U
which you would see things that have
changed one thing I have to note one
thing I have to say really quickly as
well is that the code right now the code
for Sparky by the way is is always free
and it's available on github and that is
on github home full slash the channels
are Sparky right this is the repository
however it is a bit old now it's like
two months old I plan to do an actual
push for this in about a week as so as
soon as I finish the stuff that I'm
currently working on I'm gonna push it
all to github however if you do want the
code right now or if you generally just
want to have the code as soon as I type
it pretty much then
you can support me on patreon where if
you pledge $5 or more per month you will
get access to a special version a
repository and version is a version
control system a special version
repository with pretty much all my
latest commits right again I'm never
gonna keep code from you guys everything
will eventually be available on github
but if you want to have it sooner then
you have the option of supporting me
again completely optional and I
definitely didn't expect you guys to do
it if you don't want to but it is an
option that you have available to you
okay so and that also greatly helps me
out with developing Sparky okay so we'll
get onto the stuff that's kind of
changed so API wise a lot of things have
changed
there are like gone are the days of
creating engine kind of things right so
like assets for example by creating them
by simply going new blah blah blah right
so if we try I'm trying to find a good
example here I guess all of these
textures are a great example I it almost
doesn't look like they're any different
but basically you now no longer have the
ability to say texture 2d text sequel
new texture 2d okay that's not something
that you have available to you all right
the reason is that the big thing that
I've been working on is you know from
last ever vlog is DirectX or I've been
putting direct3d into the engine and I'm
actually still going with that it's not
a hundred percent done you can say that
OpenGL does work because this is
actually using OpenGL right now to
render everything but the the big thing
is that Sparky will be supporting
multiple rendering api's so we'll begin
with direct3d because I need to get that
down so that I can start making tools
for Windows and then after that we'll
probably put involved in so anyway
because it supports multiple API is we
have this huge kind of situation where
we need to choose which one we want to
use now I'll kind of give you a
high-level overview of how this all
works because it would take an hour for
me to actually explain it but by
basically the idea is that client side
and by client I mean game side you can
specify an API when you create the
application by basically just putting it
here all right so I can change that to
direct3d it's gonna crash if I run it
there's no way that's gonna work in fact
there it is right now in fact it's just
it failed like application verification
that's how bad this is
anyway um it didn't get very far at all
actually I expected to get a lot further
but the idea is you can choose a
rendering API here which is as you can
see something that you can do at runtime
and eventually there's probably going to
be nothing that will really stop you
from being able to recreate a context
with another rendering API so it might
you you could even have this as an
in-game option to to change the renderer
into something else and that will just
of course probably it'll have to destroy
the window and rebuild a new one with a
new context so that's how you choose
that so what happens behind the scenes
is when you do choose an actual context
I'm trying to find exactly where this is
this is so ok yes our application I
think we'll be in win32 application yep
so we'll set the rendering API which is
basically something that you set on the
context which is a static render api and
you can see we have the the options up
here okay and then all that's really
used you can see that apart from context
being something that will actually be
dependent on the rendering API choose
all like that the only reason this thing
is here this render API is so that we
can basically get it right and we can
simply get the rendering API so that we
can see which one were using so how does
that happen well the way that that gets
used in the way that works a good
example is to take a look at win32
window for example when it actually
creates the window which is going to be
the same regardless of the API used you
come down to this graphics API context
create ok so this is going to create a
context with these things however when
you go into context create right into
the implementation there is a switch ok
basically we'll get the rendering
and dependent on which one will set the
context to a subclass of this class
right so for example for OpenGL we will
set it to GL context which is actually
pretty brief here in the case of
direct3d if I can even find this how did
I close that here it is if we go
direct3d you can see that first of all
it's a subclass of that with all the
kind of properties that we need here and
then you know we have a bunch of
initialization code here so that's
that's kind of the idea and everything
works like that like if I was to go into
something like texture texture is a good
hierarchy because it's actually pretty
complex we have the base texture class
which first of all these are just kind
of inputs and parameters and stuff and
actually this stuff should be a SPI API
so that we can use them game side as
well but anyway this is as you can see
all these things are implemented as
interfaces they have no fields they have
no members at all they can have static
things obviously that's completely
different but they cannot have they
cannot have members and they don't have
methods either they don't have member
methods right they can have like static
functions or whatever that's fine but
methods know right all of them are pure
virtual right so it's just a pure
interface then we have something like
texture 2d which again is a platforms
it's a plat it's a platform in specific
so it's platform independent right class
which just adds some some things that
texture to DS will typically do so it's
got a bunch of create functions so that
we can actually create it and then it's
got you know useful stuff like you're
worth get hide set data you can expand
this list of course like you eat is
something that you will that will be
expanded as time goes on and then
finally from that so this is just an
interface you have concrete
implementations you have either GL
texture 2d or we have DX texture 2d
which is actually called d 3d under all
the files if we look at all the files
here all the DirectX files start with DX
even though the class name start with J
xxx
so I probably should
change the files today 3d and then we
have all the OpenGL specific things as
well and then of course over here we
have the actual like constructors which
if I call you know texture 2d create it
will create it with the appropriate
constructor actually that's a bug right
there that should take in that and from
then on yeah that's essentially how it
works and then of course it will go into
the constructor here and that that has
all the fields that it needs like handle
and all that stuff and of course it will
even convert formats from like Sparky
texture formats to OpenGL texture
formats and and set up all that stuff
and you know DX X checker will kind of
do the same thing but in terms of
DirectX right cool so that's how that
cookie crumbles it's all pretty simple
it's a nightmare to maintain though like
to set up it is very difficult
especially cuz Sparky was more or less
kind of complete from the rendering API
side definitely not fully complete but
on its way definitely and then you know
stuff like vertex buffers kind of work
the same way well we have like a vertex
buffer which really just has like again
an independent buffer usage a bunch of
it's just an interface and then from
there we have the create function which
is a static function which returns a
point about his buffer and which one it
chooses is based on the rendering API
and of course it will then give you a
pointer back to something like this and
you have those conversions here and that
is for example how vertex buffer works
and then we have the same thing for like
an index buffer you'll switch and create
like a DirectX one for example here and
we have all that stuff kind of set up
right so it's huge you can see how many
files there are here like these are all
like platform specific ones and I
haven't even finished either the biggest
one by far is the shaders do not get me
started on that that was a nightmare
because remember I am doing like shader
passing stuff so I have to sort all that
stuff out and they work very differently
so I am making opengl work a lot like
DirectX which is a good thing because
yeah it's a generally good idea to do
that so yeah if we do take a look at
like a shader you can see after GL
shader you can see how big this clot
this interface is it's got quite a lot
quite a lot of things right so let's
kind of go through this I think I'll
cover this and they'll probably be it
for this dev look so if we take a look
at at the code here basically we've got
bind and unbind of course and then we
have all these things and these are
pretty full-on right so we've got set vs
system uniform buffer okay so that
stands for set vertex shader system
uniform buffer so these are system
uniforms meaning they are set by the
renderer
so their uniforms set by the renderer
and these are ones that are end up in
the vertex shader again in OpenGL it
doesn't matter where the uniform is
right it can be in the vertex shader and
can be in the fragment shader doesn't
matter right
well you said of a uniform you don't
have to specify which shader it goes to
in direct3d 11 at least you do have to
do that right you have to be like I want
to set this uniform on to you know the
vertex shader so that's important so now
I've obviously made up in jail work like
that as well and then we have set PS
assume you've above says that pixel
shader uniform buffer again pixels
shadow is the same as the fragment
shader and then we have user units so we
have system uniforms and we have user
uniforms and user uniforms are things
that are set by the material right and
by the actual kind of appearance right
the material of the thing is that you're
rendering rather than the actual
renderer so an example of a system
uniform would be like the camera right
an example of a user uniform would be
like the color or the or texture
actually come to coming to textures
there are also resources right so
textures are basically resources man
this is actually so much work it took me
so long anyway um so we have all this
stuff and then we can of course retrieve
them and get whatever so that's if we
look at one implementation of a shader
let's take a look at GL shader you can
see that this is a pretty big class so
what we have here are all of the kind of
things that we need so we have those set
these are system uniforms because they
don't know you really should call them
system uniform buffers we have user
uniform buffers which are using uniform
buff Tek all right
so apart from having this of course you
also have this whole shady uniform thing
class which has a bunch of like this has
like three classes it's got like cherry
uniform declaration Jail uniform buffer
declaration shader struct and that's it
and then you have GL shape sorry GL
shared a uniform which has
implementations of those so we have a GL
trader uniform Balfour Declaration and
field is actually not used anymore and
then we've got GL shade a uniform
declaration as well which does all that
stuff and you can see that there is a
lot of stuff that happens here and I
would get into this but again that's
something that I can probably save for
another video and then so eventually
what happens is when you decide and look
at like this is a huge 730 finds here a
lot of shader stuff going on here so we
compile basically and eventually we come
on we come to the probably media's hope
the meatiest solution of this entire
kind of thing and that's the passing
right so we what is that all right okay
so I need to talk about that as well so
indirect tax we have these things called
constant buffers and that's essentially
kind of the same as uniforms right so in
OpenGL you kind of you're probably
familiar with going through every
uniform and setting it one by one
of course like modern implementations of
OpenGL on modern versions of OpenGL do
support uniform buffer objects but
that's something different that Sparky
currently doesn't support it will in the
future for sure
so that being said we also have to say
that OpenGL that so so currently we
don't support that right and DirectX
though that's basically the only way
that it works or at least DirectX 11 so
because of that I've made OpenGL always
support that this will be good because
when we do support uniform buffer
objects it'll be a lot easier to
implement so everything gets put into a
buffer quote unquote and that one's just
called global for now one for the vertex
shader in this case one for the fragment
shader we pass all of these different
things
right so uniforms and then we like if
it's a struct you know we we passed that
if it started on this course let's put
the SIS underscore means it's a you have
to use that naming convention it means
it's the it's a it'll be put into the
system uniforms basically you can see
that we put it into the uniform buffers
instead of the user uniform buffers and
oh man sorry this is just so fresh on me
that I really don't I've spent like a
week on this so I really kind of don't
even want to talk about it right now but
I will make some kind of follow-up video
when this is kind of cooled down a bit
then we have uniform structs and so
eventually what will happen is when we
resolve uniforms either when we actually
retrieve locations for them we don't
need this anymore
we we you know for structs for example
we have to retrieve them using the you
know name dot field name and that's how
you get a location for them and we fill
all that out then we go through the
resources this is worth noting if
something if what if while we're passing
a uniform we detected it is a it is a
resource right which right now just
means is either a sampler two days and
put cube or sampler 2d shadow well if we
detected it's a resource well first of
all we add it to want to see where we
are first of all we add it to the
resources right and this is a shadow
resource declaration which is a little
bit different than a shader kind of
thing that's then been a normal uniform
and the reason it's different is because
direct axe actually does separate them
but it as it should really be because
they are very different things and so
what we do is when we're resolving
uniforms over here what we actually do
is we go through we go through we grab
the location of course of the like the
sampler in jail cell and we straight
away we just set it okay and they are
set in chronological order again it does
not matter what they get set to we also
set sampler arrays here as well so for
example the batch renderer which is the
default shader has a an array of Sam
platoon of sampler two days it's got 32
of them in fact so it sets them all the
way 0 through 31 ok and this just gets
set
basically a trader creation time and
does not get touched from then on now
the resource declaration is aware of
what slot it's bound to it knows what
the sampler indexes right so like for
example the fifth the fifth sampler that
appears now sure there will be you know
slot for basically so if we're on that
slot what happens is [ __ ] since it is a
shared resource declaration which has a
name and and it knows which slot it's in
when we actually do set it all we know
which GL active texture we need to set
it to because we we we say hang on which
uniform we trying to set this texture -
let's get the resource declaration and
let's get the slot for that and then we
set it it's kind of complicated but it
works very well and it means that we
never have to worry about setting
uniforms fish it for like samplers and
for caches ever again we just set
textures now which is how it should be
and then yeah I mean there's a lot of
stuff here as well that kind of works
and then we have of course the best kind
OpenGL ones which really should be
surrounded by alcohol but and there we
have them all right and then that links
very closely with materials now there
are two new things as PBR material which
extends material or subclass of material
which just has some useful functions
that's all you can see it doesn't
actually have any fields at all it's
just got these aren't used anymore
either they're old school I'll delete
them so you can see there for example
for setting albedo with sets using
albedo map to zero which because we're
using a color and all other thing again
a lot of stuff to explain oh man alright
so and then we do the albedo color and
we do all this stuff and it basically
just helps us with setting stuff that's
all but the way that in materials the
way that we set uniforms again is really
simple
we just simply have to call we just
simply have to call set uniform right or
set texture so that texture is probably
a little bit more exciting when you set
a texture you have to set it to a
uniform straight away right so if I've
got something let's look at the PBR
shader if I've
something called in my PPR shadow if
I've got something called a new
environment map which is a sample cube
right I have to say set texture new
environment map whatever texture right
and then what that will do is it'll find
the declaration for the resource so it
knows which slot it's in or which
registered send register slot same thing
right in DirectX they're called
registers and then what happens is well
we we add it to that to that correct
slot in a vector and so now we have that
slot and then when it's time to actually
bind the material it will go through all
the textures and bind them to the
appropriate slot therein so scenario we
had that sampler as I said the sampler
uniform gets set to four which means
that it gets set to textures since the
slot the web using is a register it gets
lit gets set to index four in the
textures array so when we're iterating
over it to bind it
we of course go to I equals 4 and we
bind the texture which if it's a texture
2d for example doesn't actually matter
they all kind of work the same sorry GL
texture 2d then it says gel active
texture equal to 0 plus slot right so
it'll set it to GL action or texture 4
and there we have it so it's all
automatic which is lovely because
there's having to do that manually it's
absolutely awful and that's kind of it
right there's again there's so much more
stuff another big thing that I did was
before fonts used to I used to let free
type GL create the font texture and now
it doesn't do that I said I'm still
using free type GL to properly layout
the atlas from free type and then what
happens is I simply create a texture and
I set the data to that outlets data and
that's all I'm doing
right so I'm kind of it's always it's
like the code that used to be in the
Atlas at the very bottom that does this
stuff this now doesn't do anything in
fact if this should really return I kind
of forgot to imagine that or like did
this code
really just doesn't need to exist
anymore that's what it used to do now
it's properly handled by Sparky all we
do is we set we mark it as dirty as well
which means that that's another thing
that I added actually to free type GL
here to the texture atlas
so that basically when more glyphs get
out it's at that texture it will update
the outlets right which will basically
just reset the data which will just be
called GL Texas Elementary and reset the
dollar again anyway
yeah so that way fonts work now without
having to without that system which is
important because obviously free type GL
I still want to actually use free type
GL for DirectX so that'll be fun again
all I really need for you type GL for is
to generate that texture for me I don't
need it to upload it to OpenGL or
anything like that it's just it just
needs to it just needs to generate those
pixels for me that's all I want from it
alright cool and you can see obviously
my phone rendering is still working even
though even though that's crazy even
though I'm not using pretty a gel for
that okay cool
so anyway that is the way that that
works the other thing that I quickly
added which I haven't actually I've
begun to kind of add it but I haven't
yet which you might have noticed if you
look at really anything that allocate
that allocates memory is SP new right so
instead of using the C++ new that's
actually an overlord there's a well
there's SP new which is a macro so I've
created a file called memory dot H which
is in system for now and basically all
that does is well the macro just kind of
also inserts file in line so we know
where the allocations are coming from
but right now again they're really
really simple The Oval
I've overloaded operator new and delete
by the way which just means that I can
do custom allocation stuff right now
again they're just returning malloc
besides they're just there so that I can
kind of debug better right so if I have
really large allocations for example
with this I can assert so this is very
common where you try it when you try to
for example create a new array with an
uninitialized variable as the size and
it's sort of set to like four billion
then
of course this will immediately
ascertain you me like alright instead of
maybe working somewhat and then failing
later and being hotter debug that's nice
but eventually of course Sparky will
support custom alligators and at least
will be you know in debug mode for
example but also very will always verify
that the heap is not corrupt anytime we
allocate more memory and there's all
this kind of debug stuff that we can do
with this as well as add custom
alligators to speed up a performance
like a lot right anyway so I've kind of
started working on more system stuff I'm
still kind of working on graphics though
and I obviously know that I'm doing
DirectX that's very important but yeah I
mean I was looking at it the other day
and Sparky is actually becoming a really
big project if we look at source so this
is in Sparky core this is all code that
I've personally written so this isn't
like dependencies or anything if we
actually take a look at the property is
244 files right so this is not a small
project anymore which is and I was well
reminded of that when I try to again put
in DirectX and it's also like one other
thing I wanted to mention was that the
batch render and stuff is becoming very
kind of platform independent as well you
can see we just do index buffer create
for example vertex buffer vertex array
create vertex array is just a collection
of vertex buffers that's all it is it
doesn't actually use oh that's the other
thing OpenGL no longer uses vertex
arrays this will create a GL vertex
array which doesn't actually create an
OpenGL vertex array it just yeah there's
no such thing as that anymore we're not
using vertex array only buddies buffers
which basically just means that for
example we know DirectX well I do not
click on that which which means that
like the layout for the buffer has to
get reset every time we we bind it which
is a bit annoying but anyway again
that's the choice I've made that's not
by necessity that we that were not using
vertex arrays anymore so some some
things to iron out here but it does kind
of work so yeah anyway that's pretty
much it guys I hope you enjoyed this
video I hope you saw the
cool stuff that I'm doing I hope you
learned a little bit at least yeah I
mean just so much work so much work
alright cool so thanks for watching if
you did enjoy
Sparky then please support it on patreon
the link will be in the description
there and if you'd like of course I
should be coming out with some more
videos I've had a lot of requests from
you guys to make some like OpenGL like
an OpenGL series and I think I will
probably start like pre-production on
that in the next few weeks so I'll stop
thinking about it and I'll start jotting
down some ideas and formatting it a bit
and hopefully it should come out maybe
in a month or so and we can start kind
of working on that so I'm really excited
to do that as well because I want to get
back into making tutorials for you guys
but I think I'm covered pretty much all
that there is to cover yeah so if you
enjoyed the video please hit the like
button and I'll see you guys next time
goodbye